[Music]
so where do you see open source
contributions
making a real benefit in your personal
life or in the life of the folks who
work for you that's a great question
uh so first yeah you're definitely right
it takes a lot of time a lot of energy
but i think we all think first it's
nothing is mandatory we don't
force people to contribute you know
within the team uh we encourage them we
want to help them do so we want to
you know give them the tools and the
help so that they can be the most
efficient contributors
but then as you said it is something
which is very time consuming i think the
benefit comes as in
first people are very proud to
contribute to open source community
visit this you know this really is
feeling like you know i've
i've been able to like give back to a
framework that i use
a lot so i think this is a huge drive
for everyone
two of your colleagues will be speaking
at pi data global will they be sharing
some of the research that they've done
with the pi data global community yeah
exactly yeah we're very happy this year
we had uh
two to talk one by alexander abraham is
going to be talking about active
learning which is a
great topic we have around labeling and
we actually open source our own solution
which is called cardinal
so we have a talker called cardino a
matrix-based active learning framework
and then we have another research
scientist of ours which is similar
maggio
who studied this year globally what we
call national
debugging and it's about learning and
understanding
uh where you model make mistakes so it's
called learning from your model's
mistake
so tell me a little bit more about the
local efforts that iku
has made to support the local
communities i understand data who's a
big supporter of
the pi data paris meetup group what
motivates you to support
these local communities in that way i
think you know
we we used to be a small startup when i
joined that iq we were i know maybe 20.
now we're about 500 people uh and so i
know what it is to be
uh to have you know limited uh
i would say funds to be in a small
office and so
usually we see that those type of
efforts from the community you know they
kind of struggle sometime to find
right just you know just a room to have
people
meet and talk so that's what we did
earlier this year before the kaveed we
did that with
uh the paris paediata we host the meet
up we were super happy to do so and you
know it's another way i think
for us to give back you know it's not
only about giving back and contributing
as a researcher or as an engineer it's
also giving back as you know we
we can afford to you know to have people
stay with us at the office
we also did that with sprints where we
hosted some sprints
uh that was another great way to to be
embedded in the uh
local activities of uh of the data sense
uh ecosystem here in paris but also in
new york
so yeah that's what we do
[Music]
you